When I'm in the water, if I forget
everything and live in the moment,
I don't feel any different, well, I don't feel
like a person with a disability, I
feel like a person just like the one who
is with me.
My name is Roberto Alejandro Ramírez
Rivas and I'm 24 years old.  of age I had a
car accident
November 12, 2011 I fractured my
neck at 15 and
6 which leaves me with a spinal cord injury
when Roberto Ingresos had limited
all the functions of his body from the
head down,
not
and
today
with all  The therapies that he was
receiving were little by little moving his
arms in his hands.
I am Chicana.
I direct abuses without barriers. Prison.
The underwater world offers something
incomparable to people with
disabilities, for example, people
like 'Tito' who have little
physical mobility in the  Land
in the water changes everything
[Music]
Of course, after the accident, if
you lose freedom
for everyone, I
had to depend on someone,
but not
the actions.  activities that showed access
before an accident were all
those activities that had to do
with the sea
I felt free
the story with Tito has been a
very interesting story for
us because knowing that he was
very interested in matters of the sea it
was  invite him to participate in the
questions of the course
and what we did was get a
very interesting team of museum instructors who
fell in love with the project and that they
could transmit attitude because all
the knowledge and experiences to be
able to take it again
[Music]
oblivion from still nothing  but it's you and
the bottom of the sea and you feel that freedom
that I had long ago
and down there
[Music]
how